[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
der 9 November 1773 ist kein Tag für
einen Ausflug es ist neblig und kalt ein
Wetter in dem man sich den Tod holen
kann doch alle sind sie gekommen um zu
sehen wie der Tod sich eine von ihnen
holt neben dem Richtblock steht der
Freimann der Scharfrichter er trägt
einen grillroten Mantel mit goldenen
Worten sein Gesicht ist von einer ebenso
roten Zipfelmütze mit zwei Löchern für
die Augen verdeckt
Eva kniet in einem einfachen grauen
gewandt vor dem Richtblock ein paar
Meter entfernt ragt das Rad im Tor
auf seinem Rand hat sich eine Krähe
niedergelassen als wissen sie genau dass
hier gleich ein frisches warmes Mahl
bereitet wird
ein Gehilfe des freimanns schlägt auf
den Rand um sie zu vertreiben
als die fernen Glocken der geteilten
Kirche von Gemünd im Kärnten verklingen
verließ der landgerichtsdiener das
Urteil
auf Clarke und Antwort red und gegenreht
auch algerichtliches an- und beibringen
und der Täterin selbst eigenbekanntes
nach ist gesprochen worden folgendes
Urteil
es solle die beim löblichen
hochgräflichen Land gut Gmünd ob krimin
venefizii in Maritim komissi
prozessierte evakari nach abermaliger
Bekenntnis ihres Verbrechen durch den
landesfürstlichen Freimann an der
gewöhnlichen richtstadt durch das
Schwert von Leben zum Tod hingerichtet
die rechte Hand abgeschlagen Kopf und
Hand an das Rad aufgesteckt und der
Körper in Lupus duplizit begraben werden
zu ihrer wohl verdienten Schlaf andern
aber zu einem Beispiel
unterzeichnet und besiegelt dr Benedikt
Alfons Edler von empaga bahnrichter
es geht schnell
wenigstens geht es schnell als der
Körper der Frau in Lokus Suizide der
ungeweiten Erde am Hinrichtungsort
verscharrt ist und die Menge sich
zerstreut kommt die Krähe zurück landet
auf dem Rand des hochragenden Rades und
betrachtet einen Moment den Kopf und die
Hand die daran aufgespießt sind
der Hingerichteten zur straf andern aber
zu einem Beispiel wie es im Urteil
gefordert war der Vogel weiß nichts von
Schuld und Strafe ihn kümmert nicht der
Blick der toten Augen im Fallen Gesicht
der Frau für ihn ist heute ein Festtag
er hat schon viel zu lange warten müssen
bis die großen zweibeinigen Wesen mit
ihren endlosen plappereien fertig waren
und endlich das Festmahl zubereitet
haben schnell schlägt er seinen Schnabel
in den saftigen Augapfel
Mahlzeit so begrüßt du mich also aus dem
Urlaub zurück Mirko alles klar
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem täglichen truecrime
Podcast mein Name ist Toni Heyer und ich
bin Mirko Kasimir heute erzählen wir die
tragische Geschichte der evakari besser
bekannt als Eva verstauener oder Eva
verschaunerin das Ende der Geschichte
das kennt ihr ja schon ja wobei wir uns
bei der Schilderung ein bisschen
Freiheit erlaubt haben wir wissen
natürlich nicht ob es die Krähe auf dem
Rad wirklich gab aber naja wir wollen
hier auch ein bisschen Geschichten
erzählen aber keine Sorge ansonsten
bleiben wir bei den Fakten soweit sie
fest stehen und da wo wir nur
spekulieren können dabei sind wir euch
darauf hin Mirko erzähl mal wie
verfassunger wird am 21 Dezember 1737 in
Malta geboren das hat nichts mit der
gleichnamigen Insel zu tun sondern ist
eine kleine Gemeinde in Kärnten im Süden
Österreichs die Familie lebt im
höchstgelegen Hof am Malta Berg der
faschauner Huber also ziemlich abgelegen
eva ist die jüngste Tochter von
Christian verschauner und Maria Huber
sie hat eine ältere Schwester und zwei
Brüder aber die beiden sterben im
Kleinkindalter also auch ihre Mutter
stirbt eva ist da gerade elf oder zwölf
da heiratet ihr Vater Christian nach
kurzer Zeit wieder und Eva bekommt bald
zwei kleine Halbschwestern aber
männlicher Nachwuchs bleibt aus und
natürlich war das für den Besitzer eines
Hofes vor 250 Jahren ein Riesenproblem
eine seiner Töchter soll den Hof
übernehmen aber das ist damals nur
denkbar wenn sie einen Mann an ihrer
Seite hat da die älteste Schwester
bereits verheiratet und weggezogen ist
soll Eva heiraten und mit ihrem Ehemann
den Hof bewirtschaften es ist die
einzige Möglichkeit das Erbe zu sichern
Eva dürfte davon nicht allzu begeistert
gewesen sein es heißt sie wolle ledig
bleiben
wohl immer wieder Heiratswillige Männer
bei ihr und ihrem Vater anklopfen sie
muss wohl ziemlich hübsch gewesen sein
und vor allem als erbendes gutgehenden
Hofes eine verdammt gute Partie als 1770
zwei Brautwerber im Namen eines gewissen
Jakob Kari aus untermalta bei den
verschauenden vorstellig werden lehnt
sie nicht sofort ab sondern besucht
schon am nächsten Tag zusammen mit ihrem
Vater den Hof von Jakob ist eigentlich
sehr verwunderlich wo hältst dieser
Umschwung kommt also warum sie jetzt
doch heiraten will und dazu noch diesen
Jakob der galt als nah und hatte bisher
bei allen brautwerbungen und dicken
Körper behalten also warum sollte sich
ausgerechnet die hübsche faschaunerin
den trotzigen Ladenhüter aus dem Dorf
aussuchen
der Vater scheint sie nicht gedrängt zu
haben denn es gibt Berichte nach denen
er sie lieber bei sich behalten wollte
und fürchtete sie als Arbeitskraft zu
verlieren ja aber sie war nicht nur
hübsch sie war auch sehr tüchtig
und Eva scheint es mit der Angst zu tun
bekommen zu haben der Angst davor ihr
Leben als alte Jungfer auf dem Hof zu
verbringen und den dann vielleicht an
den Ehemann einer der Halbschwestern zu
verlieren aber das ist nicht ganz belegt
okay Vater und Tochter besuchen also die
Karies in untermalta und Eva ist
geschockt der Hof ist heruntergekommen
und überschuldet ein Treppen wie man
sagt ein armseliges Anwesen gar kein
Vergleich zum properen Sascha und Hof
die ganze Familie macht auf Eva keinen
besonders guten Eindruck Jakob selbst
scheint ziemlich einfältig und steht
unter der Fuchtel von Tandel Eva eine
Verwandten die den Hof für ihn führt
seine Mutter und sein Vater sind
gestorben doch er hat noch die zweite
Frau seines Vaters an der Backe
Stiefmutter Katharina Kari die er auf
den Tod nicht ausstehen kann ja und dann
gibt es da auch noch eine ledige Markt
mit einem kleinen Kind
sozusagen ein letzter Grußform
verstorbenen Vater wenn man das so sagen
will Evas Vater ist gegen die Ehe aber
Eva hat sich warum auch immer jetzt in
den Kopf gesetzt das ist der Jakob sein
soll und sie kann ihren Vater überreden
die Schulden des karrischen Hofs zu
übernehmen er willigt ein auch in die
Hochzeit aber die ganze Sache zerrüttet
das Verhältnis zwischen den beiden
nachhaltig die ganze Ehe steht wegen der
Situation auf dem Hof und dem Streit mit
dem Vater unter gar keinen guten Stern
schon am Hochzeitstag scheint Eva
Bedenken gekommen zu sein und fast hätte
sie kurz vor dem endgültigen ja in der
Kirche einen Rückzieher gemacht ja für
Jakob den Narren ist es natürlich der
Hauptgewinn eine schöne Frau der Hof
endlich schuldenfrei und irgendwann wird
auch der fahrschaunerhof der Familie
gehören von Anfang an haben es die Markt
und Jakobs Stiefmutter Katharina auf Eva
abgesehen sie zerreißen sich im Haus im
Dorf das Maul über die Ehe und über die
Ehefrau als Eva sich bei Jakob darüber
beschwert verspricht er die Stiefmutter
des Hauses zu verweisen doch dazu kommt
es nicht mehr 9 März 1770 vier Wochen
und drei Tage sind die beiden
verheiratet eva hat gekocht Partner
Nudeln nicht das was wir normalerweise
unter Nudeln verstehen also keine Pasta
sondern große gefüllte Teigtaschen eine
traditionelle Fastenspeise es hat allen
geschmeckt und das ist so ziemlich das
einzige worauf sie später alle
Beteiligten einigen können alle
Überlebenden Beteiligten sollte man an
dieser Stelle vielleicht sagen obwohl es
lecker war bleibt eine Nudel übrig die
Nudel des Todes
okay klingt wie ein Vorschlag für einen
neuen Indiana Jones Film na ja okay wie
auch immer nach dem Essen machen sich
alle wieder an die Arbeit
Eva nimmt die übrig gebliebene Nudel
schneidet sie auf und gibt sie in eine
Pfanne am Nachmittag als die Tiere
gefüttert sind kommt Jakob hungrig in
die Küche
Eva verspricht ihm eine kleine Extra
Mahlzeit und brät die übrig gebliebene
Nudel in Butterschmalz an streckt das
ganze mit Brotstücken und serviert sie
ihm also ich muss sagen wenn ich das so
höher habe ich richtig Bock auf
Maultaschen wer hat Toni aber ohne diese
eine spezielle Zutat du meinst genau
aber dazu kommen wir gleich dem Jakob
schmeckt's jedenfalls er bietet Eva an
mit zu essen wie gesagt die Dinger
konnten ziemlich groß sein bisschen zur
Größe einer Faust und Eva hat das ganze
Jahr mit Schmalz und Brot noch
ordentlich gestreckt aber Eva lehnt ab
sie habe keinen besonderen Appetit sagt
sie stattdessen ist die Stiefmutter den
letzten Happen und kratzt die Pfanne
ordentlich aus da die Tagesarbeit des
Bauern erledigt ist beschließt Jakob
seinen Freund und Nachbarn den
meisterbauern zu besuchen normalerweise
bleibt er dort für eine ganze Zeit aber
an diesem Tag kehrt er schon bald nach
Hause zurück ihm ist schlecht und bald
muss er sich auch Erbrechen Eva gibt ihm
Milch und saure Milch als Hausmittel
aber er kann nichts im Magen behalten
dann wird auch der Stiefmutter übel und
schließlich auch Eva selbst so behauptet
sie zumindest die beiden Frauen und der
Bauer liegen dann nieder bei Jakob
kommen Schüttelfrost und ein
unstillbares Durstgefühl dazu sein Herz
rast und kein Hausmittel will helfen vor
allem weil er es sofort wieder erbricht
am Samstag geht es Eva und der
Stiefmutter besser doch Jakobs Zustand
verschlimmert sich immer weiter am Abend
schickte Eva den Knecht zum Pfarrer da
fürchtet sie wohl schon das Schlimmste
beziehungsweise hofft das Schlimmste wir
werden sehen
der Pfarrer erscheint er nimmt Jakob die
Beichte ab auf die Kommunion muss er
verzichten weil er nichts bei sich
behalten kann und man wohl nicht
riskieren will dass er die Hostie wieder
auskotzt
der Pfarrer untersucht ihn wohl auch
prüft sogar den Puls und befindet das
eigentlich kein Grund zur Sorge bestehe
der Bauer habe sich nur den Magen
verdorben ja vielleicht ist es besser
wenn sich die Pfarrer um die Seele
kümmern und den Körper anderen also
Experten überlassen
jetzt war es wahrscheinlich schwer in
einem abgelegenen Dorf in Kärnten im
Jahr 1770 ein Arzt heranzuschaffen aber
es gab ja auch noch die Bader die man
sich als Mischung aus Wunder Doktor und
Jahrmarkt Clown vorstellen kann wir
wissen nicht ob so einer gerade greifbar
gewesen wäre und ob er wirklich hätte
helfen können oder nur mit aderlessen
und was weiß ich noch allem ist nur
hätte noch schlimmer gemacht und
natürlich hätte er auch bezahlt werden
müssen und ich meine der Pfarrer hat sie
ja beruhigt also lassen Sie es einfach
erstmal dabei am nächsten Morgen geht es
dem Bauern aber noch schlechter trotzdem
geht seine Frau wie gewohnt zu
Sonntagsmesse dort trifft sie ihren
Vater und erzählt ihm von Jacobs
Krankheit und er begleitet sie dann mit
nach Hause als sie dort eintreffen ist
deutlich dass sich der Bauer nicht nur
den magenkt hat sein Körper ist
aufgedunsten Gesicht und Lippen sind
blau gefärbt doch noch immer zögert die
Bäuerin einen Bade gerufen am frühen
Sonntagnachmittag stirbt Jakob Kary der
Pfarrer der ihn am Tag zuvor zuletzt
gesehen hat notiert im Sterbebuch der
Gemeinde es starb mit dem Sakrament der
Beichte gleichwohl ohne hochheilige
sterbekommunion wegen ununterbrochenem
Erbrechen und es wurde auch keine
heilige letzte Ölung durchgeführt wegen
nicht Erkennung der Todesgefahr Jakob
Kari Bauer an der hörlhube in Unterdorf
im Alter von 35 Jahren bald werden die
Gerüchte unüberhörbar ist es nicht
merkwürdig dass die frisch gebackene
Witwe nicht geweint hat und völlig
ungerührt scheint weil der Toten Wache
ist einigen Frauen aus dem Dorf die
blaue Gesichtsfarbe aufgefallen einige
beschwören sie hätten des Nachts einen
rumoren im Bauch des Toten gehört als ob
eine Lawine abgeht sagen sie
naja ich meine ganze wild wirds wohl
nicht geklungen haben ich nehme an dass
das wohl eher irgendwelche verdauungs-
oder verwesungsgase waren die da ihr
Unwesen getrieben haben
Jakob wird begraben aber die Gerüchte
verstummen nicht von Giftmord ist die
Rede von hedrach oder Hüttenrauch hier
und heute besser bekannt als Arsenik ein
Gift dessen besitzt zu jener Zeit streng
verboten ist das aber trotzdem in vielen
Bauernhöfen irgendwo im Schrank steht
ganz besonders in dieser Gegend denn nur
wenige Kilometer von Malta entfernt wird
Arsenik abgebaut und aufbereitet man
verwendet es als Medizin für das Vieh
und manchmal auch als Droge als eine Art
alten Kokain in sehr geringer Dosis
steigert es den Appetit für zu
allgemeinem Wohlbefinden und gilt als
Stärkungsmittel wie gesagt wir sprechen
hier von sehr geringen Dosen und wehe
man vertut sich dabei in Österreich soll
das Arsenik Essen noch bis nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg verbreitet gewesen
sein das ist ziemlich lang
schließlich laden die Behörden im
nahegelegenen Gmünd Eva vor und befragen
sich Eva streitet ab Arsen ins Essen
gemischt zu haben sie besäße auch keins
doch damit gibt man sich nicht zufrieden
der landgerichtsdiener von Gmünd bringt
den Fall zur Anzeige daraufhin schickt
das Gericht ihn und zwei Knechte nach
Malta um die Familie im Auge zu behalten
dann reist eine Gerichtskommission an
bestehend aus einem Landrichter einem
Chirurgen einem Bader und einem
Beisitzer ein Schreiber und ein
kirchenbediensteter aus Malta ergänzen
die Kommission als Einheimische alle
Beteiligten werden einzeln beim Kramer
wird in Malta befragt parallel exhumiert
man den Leichnam von Jakob Kary und
obduziert ihn der Arzt stellt fest dass
die inneren Organe gesund sind nur ein
paar Entzündungen fallen ihm auf und
eine seltsame Absonderung als er die auf
Bluttropfen lässt breitet sich ein
Knoblauchgeruch aus und ist gilt als
sicherer Hinweis darauf dass tatsächlich
Gift im Spiel war höchstwahrscheinlich
Arsenik in der Vernehmung sagen einige
der Bewohner des Hofes aus dass dort
entgegen Evas Aussage sehr wohl Arsenik
vorhanden war um es bei viel Krankheiten
oder beim Abkalben zu verwenden am
nächsten Tag bringt man Eva als
Verdächtige Nacht Gmünd als man sie aus
der kramerwirtschaft führt sieht sie
ihren Vater sie wirft sich auf dem Boden
ihm zu Füßen und schreit er solle sie
nicht verlassen
Evan Kari geborene fascha wird der
Prozess gemacht und der zieht sich hin
zwei Jahre sitzt Eva im Kerker und
gesteht nichts doch die Indizien
sprechen gegen Sie Eva behauptet
Stiefmutter und Markt sein beim
Zubereiten der angeblich vergifteten
Nudel zugegen gewesen doch beide sagen
aus dass Eva allein in der Küche gewesen
sein Entschuldigung wir erinnern uns mal
kurz das könnte natürlich auch bedeuten
dass sich die Markt und die Stiefmutter
die Eva eh nicht leiden konnten ganz
einfach zu einer Lüge verabredet haben
des weiteren habe Eva ihren Mann und
später auch ihre Stiefmutter
aufgefordert von der Nudel zu essen sie
selbst habe sie aber nicht angerührt
außerdem habe sie nach dem Tod ihres
Mannes teilnahmslos gewirkt und nicht
geweint ja okay ganz ehrlich ich finde
wir sollten uns hier nicht rausnehmen
darüber zu urteilen wie jemand trauert
oder eben nicht
und wir wissen ja auch dass sie nicht
besonders happy in ihrer kurzen Ehe war
das bedeutet ja aber nicht dass sie dann
automatisch die Täterin ist und ihn
umgelegt hat vom Arsen dass man im Haus
findet ist ein Stückchen abgebrochen
okay aber das ist doch absurd das kann
doch jede oder jeder gewesen sein die
mag die Stiefmutter vielleicht sogar der
längst verstorbene Vater denn man weiß
ja nicht einmal wann da etwas
abgebrochen wurde da hast du verdammt
recht Toni es gab eine ganze Reihe
solcher Indizien naja manche kann man
nicht mal Indizien nennen aber das alles
reichte selbst damals nicht für eine
Verurteilung und wenn die Beweise nicht
reichen und die Angeklagte nicht
gestehen will ja dann gibt es nur noch
eine andere Möglichkeit ich würde jetzt
gerne sagen Freispruch aber du meinst
natürlich genau am 20 Juni 172 evakari
sitzt da schon mehr als zwei Jahre im
Gefängnis wird der Fall an den Landes
menschlichen bandrichter Benedikt Alfons
von Emberger übertragen der nach
weiteren Vernehmungen im August bei der
landeshauptmannschaft den Antrag stellt
die Angeklagte entweder freilassen oder
sie peinlich befragen zu dürfen also zu
foltern er erhält die Genehmigung zur
peinlichen Befragung allerdings soll es
erst mit der sogenannten schreckung
versucht werden die schreckung findet am
27 Oktober 1772 statt man führt evakari
in die Folterkammer wo man ihr den
Scharfrichter mit dem verhüllten Gesicht
und dem grillroten Mantel zeigt und die
Folterinstrumente die schreckung wirkt
die Frage steht in Mord doch als ich
später erneut befragt wird kann oder
will sie nichts darüber sagen wie und
wie viel Gift sie dem Essen beiget hat
der Mann Richter beantragt erneut die
Folter und bekommt erneut die
Genehmigung diesmal
ohne die Einschränkung sie erst zu
schrecken am 4 februar wird sie der
Schnürung unterzogen sie sitzt auf einem
Schemel Hände und Füße sind mit dünnen
Seilen gefesselt diese werden von zwei
folterknichten mit Walzen
zusammengezogen was unerträgliche
Schmerzen bereitet
erneut und erklärt die Tat in allen
Einzelheiten weil sie als Täterin die
Details kennt oder weil sie sich das
alles ausdenkt weil sie weiß dass es die
einzige Möglichkeit ist weiteren
Torturen zu entgehen
also echt Folter das ist ein absurdes
Konzept lassen wir mal die ganze
Unmenschlichkeit beiseite ich meine
darüber müssen wir echt nicht reden aber
das ist doch absolut kein Instrument zur
Wahrheitsfindung ja da muss man nur an
sowas wie die Hexenprozesse Mittelalter
denken als Menschen vor allem Frauen die
verrücktesten Dinge gestanden haben vom
buchstäblichen Ritt auf dem Besen
bisschen zu Sex mit dem Teufel und
anderem Unsinn weil sie lieber auf dem
Scheiterhaufen sterben wollten als
weiterhin gefolter zu werden lieber ein
Ende mit Schrecken als Schrecken ohne
Ende zumal sie wussten dass am Ende doch
der Tod wartete ganz egal wie lange Sie
den Fehler rein widerstehen und nichts
zu gaben und so muss es auch Eva
gegangen sein sie muss inzwischen
gewusst haben dass es für sie keinen Weg
zurück in die Freiheit gab die Folter
war ein Instrument um Geständnisse zu
produzieren echte oder aus Verzweiflung
erfundene ganz offensichtlich ist es
damals nicht in erster Linie darum
gegangen die waren Täter vermitteln und
zu bestrafen sondern vor allem darum ja
irgendwie ein Gleichgewicht herzustellen
etwas Schreckliches war geschehen also
musste jemand dafür bestraft werden wer
und ob er oder sie etwas damit zu tun
hatten das war zweitrangig und die Welt
schien wieder im Lot und die Autoritäten
hatten gezeigt dass kein Verbrechen
ungesund bleibt schaut her wir haben ein
Geständnis wir haben der Gerechtigkeit
Genüge getan niemand entgeht unserer
strafenden Hand und glücklicherweise
setzte sich in dieser Zeit langsam die
Erkenntnis durch das Geständnisse die
unter Folter erlangt werden absolut
wertlos sind unglücklicherweise zu
langsam für evakari geborene faschauna
sie war eine der letzten vielleicht die
letzte die in Österreich aufgrund
solcher Methoden verurteilt wurde im
Jahr 1776 wurde die Folter in Österreich
abgeschafft am 20 März 1773 nach drei
Jahren im Kerker wird der verschaunerin
das Urteil verkündet
wir haben es am Anfang gehört Eva stellt
ein Gnadengesuch an Kaiserin Maria
Theresia das jedoch abgelehnt wird am 9
November 1773 stirbt sie auf der Gmünder
Richtstätte dem galgenbichl
und damit sind wir am Ende unserer
heutigen Geschichte danke dass ihr heute
mit dabei wart und dass ihr auch
hoffentlich nächstes Mal wieder mit
einschaltet eure Toni und euer Mirko
unsere wichtigste Quelle für diese Folge
waren verschiedene Beiträge in der
karinzia vor allem aus den Jahren 1958
und 1964 die über die Website der
Österreichischen Nationalbibliothek
verfügbar sind die Links dazu haben wir
in der Wikipedia gefunden deren sehr
guter und umfangreicher Artikel einen
guten und detailreichen Überblick über
den Fall bietet